[MUSIC PLAYING]
MODERATOR: The
Gardner lecture given
by the Department of Aeronautics
and Astronautics at MIT.
Lester Gardner was a
friend of the department,
was interested
throughout his career
in aeronautical
engineering, and was
instrumental in creating
the Hunsaker professorship.
He was mostly a publicist of the
field of aerospace engineering
as it's now called,
and was the publisher
for more than 10 years of
aviation and aeronautical
engineering, and was
quite a noted contributor
in his own right to
aeronautical engineering
in the middle of the century.
Today, for only the second time
in the history of the lecture,
we have two lecturers
who will jointly,
and in a somewhat coordinated
fashion, give the lecture.
This past week was
the 10th anniversary
of the flight of the
Daedalus airplane,
human powered airplane,
from Crete to Santorini,
perhaps recreating the
mythical flight of Daedalus.
Are you going to talk
about the myth, John?
You are.
I won't take any more
of John's ammunition.
And we thought it was
an appropriate time
to commemorate the entire
history of human powered flight
and asked two of the principals
to come and be with us
today to share their
view of this history
from the insider's view.
I can recall, literally
as a young man,
that we had at MIT a
series of I believe
it was three
symposia on low speed
and motorless flight in the
late '60s and early '70s,
largely organized by
the late Jim Nash Weber,
and brought together
at that time
some of the leading
figures and builders
of human powered airplanes
up to that point.
And my recollection of
them was the last of them
was in about 1974.
Does anyone remember if that's--
'76.
And that was still before
any of the Kremer prizes
had actually been won if
my recollection serves me.
Is that right?
Yeah.
So we decided to make this,
in some sense, a joint event,
that there was
today are organized
by Mark Drela and
Carolyn [? Thotusky, ?]
the technical symposium
on low speed and motorless
flight, to bring together
some of the ongoing technical
efforts in that area and
then followed by the lecture
this afternoon.
Well, let me introduce very
briefly our two lecturers.
THey're, interestingly,
both founders and chairmen
of various small to medium
size flight vehicle companies
I guess you would say it.
Paul Macready is a figure
who needs little introduction
in the world of modern
aerospace engineering.
He's the founder and chairman
of AeroVironment, Incorporated,
a company that
builds specialized
aircraft with a
particular emphasis
on advanced electric
power systems.
He's a member of
the National Academy
and the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences.
And as you know, and probably
will hear more about,
is the father of
the Gossamer family
of lightweight human
powered vehicles.
Jon Langford is the founder,
president, and chairman
of Aurora Flight Sciences,
a company which specializes
in flight vehicles specialized
to the high altitude
environment, and
including the Perseus
proof of concept vehicle.
He was the program manager
for the Daedalus project
and the spark plug for several
of the other previous human
powered airplanes at MIT.
And in the interim
between two of those,
left MIT where he
received his degrees
to go off and work on what
became the F-117 stealth
fighter at Lockheed
Martin, or at that time
the Lockheed Corporation.
So without further
time delay, I'll
introduce Paul MacCready
who, as I understand it,
will speak first.
[APPLAUSE]
MACCREADY: Thank you
and good afternoon,
friends of airplanes, human
powered airplanes, challenges,
and fun.
This is a field that's been
going on for a long time.
There's been a huge
amount written about it.
In the short time we
have this afternoon,
there's no possible way of
going over this huge history.
So one is referenced to a
lot of books that exist.
I've written up a
version of my talk,
a version that doesn't have much
in the way of illustrations.
I'm going to show lots of
slides and videos here.
So it'll be very different.
But the written
version does have
a list of a lot of
the publications
that you can read that
really give all the details
on the facts of what
happened in this field, how
the field began, and events
that have taken place
until fairly recently.
Also, I will show towards
the end, a video doing more
with much less that shows
Gossamer Condor and Gossamer
Albatross very briefly,
which you'll be hearing
a lot about in the talk.
But also it shows some of
the things to which those
have led fitting into a theme of
the doing more with much less.
And we give copies of that
video to anybody who wants them.
But I only have a couple
of loose ones here.
But if any of you will
sign your name over there
or put a card in
the little bowls
on the far side of that
table, apparently MIT
has some way of
magically seeing to it
that you will receive
one, because we'll just
send them a bunch.
I wanted to not duplicate
what's in the written literature
but try and look a little
broader perspectives.
And the broadest perspective
is start way back looking
at what flight has meant
to creatures on earth.
Several hundred
million years ago,
it became obvious in
evolutionary survival
challenges that the air
was a wonderful avenue
to get up into away from the
things that would eat you.
And instead of having to crawl
over slimy things on the ground
and fall rocks and so on,
there is a nice, pure air
to let you escape things,
travel long distances,
look for prey, et cetera.
And there's such
value in getting up
into this added
dimension in spite
of all the difficulties
associated with it where
you have to have wings, and
need light wing loadings.
And you're fragile and you have
to have a good bit of energy
and a lot of specialization.
But the features are such
that I think something
like 3/4 of insects fly now.
And obviously, other
natural flyers--
birds, and bats, and pterosaurs
were great success stories.
And some of them still are.
To go through this
very quickly, I
want to start with
the first slide, which
shows the four arms--
one human, three belonging to
other vertebrate creatures.
And the three top ones fly.
And because this
ecological niche of flight
requires the things that grow
from little creatures' DNA
requires either
they flap something.
They're flapping their arms.
And this slide shows
that all of them have,
including humans, have the
same basic arm structure.
So they started in the flight
mode at different times
so they accomplished
it different ways.
But if you follow all four
of these back far enough,
you come to certainly
a common ancestor.
The top pterosaurs
is very simple.
And it's almost like
a big hang glider.
And the outer half
of the wing spar
is just the little finger
that extended way out.
And birds do it differently.
Bats use their fingers
as the control surfaces.
There are a lot of different
insects, some old dragonflies
I think were about
2 and 1/2 foot
wingspan back in the old days.
And even now, they are
wonderful successes,
nature's helicopters.
Birds are similar.
Hummingbirds are similar,
nature's helicopters.
And the hummingbird looks very
similar to the hawk moth, which
occupies the same flight niche.
They look the same
but one's an insect.
One's a bird.
The flyers that we're
really in awe of
are some of the more
efficient birds.
Here's an albatross.
Just magnificent for going
out over long distances
over the ocean.
And you'll notice
very high wingspan.
Looks almost like a sail plane.
And essentially no tail.
It can whip out a tail
for some tight maneuvers,
but most of the time,
it does not use one.
Same is true of the
frigate bird, which
soars on very gentle up currents
and convection over oceans,
because it's using
these weak thermals that
are about a meter a second.
It ends up as a superb low speed
soarer with low sinking speed.
The albatross using
dynamic scoring
is more like a
bullet with wings.
Goes a lot faster.
Each one fitting their niche.
And then when you
get over land, there
are many other kinds
of soaring creatures.
And you start seeing ones that
are very good at the low speed
flight, maneuverability,
all those feathers doing
interesting and, we
are beginning to learn,
very efficient things in order
to make flight work very well.
And we just had a
talk today on the way
wings should join the body.
It turns out that resulted
from a lot of advanced theory.
And it turns out they look
just like the vultures that
have been around for
100 million years.
So we're learning.
We now can see bugs,
birds, and bats fly.
But we can't see
the pterodactyls
fly because they went extinct
when the dinosaurs went extinct
65 million years ago.
As they started,
and the pterosaurs,
they were rhamphorhynchoids
with tails
like you see here, actually
rather small creatures,
more sparrowlike than the
awesome size that you see.
And then as they got
larger, as time went on,
the larger ones began
having no tails.
It turned out an ounce of brains
used an active control seemed
to be much better than
adding an extra pound of tail
on the creature.
So modern ones just flew
like ordinary creatures.
And this is a
static display model
of the largest creature
that ever flew,
the QN pterodactyl, of
which we made a flying model
to be in a movie called
On The Wing showing
the evolution of natural
flight, evolution
of technological flight.
And there were no
pterodactyls around to take
pictures of so we made a
replica, only an 18 foot one
rather than 36 foot
one, because we only
were able to get up through
the temperamental overweight
adolescent size by the
time the project was done.
But it worked.
And in the flights, it
crashed often but never
when the IMAX cameras
were pointed at it.
Somehow it knew what
its mission was.
But to have this thing
fly is just amazing.
It has no tail.
Trying to keep it
pointing forwards
like trying to shoot narrow
with the feathered end forward.
And it makes you
appreciate nature.
So wonderful on active control.
And those other birds
that I showed you
aren't using the
tail very often.
It uses active control.
Humans are edging toward that.
But most of our planes
have regular tails.
I've got a video that
will show this flying
if you start with number one.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- On January 15 this year,
in [INAUDIBLE],, California,
the modern day pterodactyl
flew for the cameras
in the Smithsonian's
widescreen film On the Wing.
A part of history we had not
witnessed more than 65 million
years ago was brought to life.
Can you imagine?
The most important
thing on this is
that it serves as a symbol and
catalyst against people's minds
[INAUDIBLE].
What it's done for us
is ensure [INAUDIBLE]
appreciate the wonderful job
mother nature does as a design.
Man will not
[INAUDIBLE] something
this large can be propelled by
biological power, by muscles.
But nature shows that it was.
But it's the same
fact [INAUDIBLE]
wanted across the planet
and realized we didn't
discover [INAUDIBLE] geography.
[INAUDIBLE] design an airplane.
It just changed the
world, because it
got people's [INAUDIBLE],, I
hope this will be a little bit
the same way.
Okay.
MACCREADY: Nature has
a lot of different ways
of having flying things, showing
you the four real fliers.
But then seeds are made so they
have pretty good aerodynamics.
Pollen is distributed
through the air.
Spiders on spiderwebs can be
transported hundreds of miles.
And there are many
different kinds of flight.
And there are flying fish.
And many of you won't believe
it but there are actually
flying squid.
And they fly in groups
and fly very beautifully.
Not very far.
All this is to emphasize
that all energy of creatures
on earth really comes from
sun with a few exceptions
and with different
time constants.
So solar power up here,
you get instantly.
Fossil fuel is stored
energy of sunlight,
maybe from many
millions of years ago.
Up here using wind and heat to
make thermals and sail planes
fly.
But also there's
food for muscles,
which is the energy that
creatures use to get around.
And so a hawk will
start with this energy.
And then we'll use
a lot that comes
from wind and the heating of
the ground making thermals.
So I've shown a
spectrum of flying
things that go from
practically no weight up
to that giant pterosaur.
And the pterosaur probably
weighed, or pterodactyl QN
and probably weighed 180 pounds
at about a 36 foot wingspan.
It was the only one of that
species, the large one,
found and I doubt that
one found the biggest.
And you look at
some scaling laws.
And there's no reason why
they couldn't have had one,
say, 40 foot in size.
And there are some
giant versions
of that hawk or
that vulture that I
showed that probably
got up to 180 pounds
and flew about 6
million years ago.
These began edging towards
people type weight.
And the giant
vulture was probably
around 20 foot
wingspan, getting up
towards span that
involves real airplanes.
So there got to be,
at the beginning
of this century, some interest
in human powered flight.
A lot more interest at the
very beginning because people
didn't know about engines.
But once engines
began, the interest
in human powered flight
sort of evaporated.
But an early prize was to see
how far you could go just using
the kinetic energy
of your momentum
as you got a bicycle
and significant prize.
Competitions like this do
help the field move along.
There's another prize put up
in the middle of the '30s.
This is one of the planes
that attempted to do it.
And they're really very
great pioneering airplanes.
Person in there pedaling.
Couldn't qu9ite climb, but
could greatly extend the glide.
But I think it then sandbagged
with the requirement
of the government,
I believe in Italy,
that this had to
meet all the strength
requirements of regular
commercial aircraft
even though it would never
fly higher than 10 feet.
And that rather limited it.
It was a great
pioneering effort.
And then a big
moment in this field,
there had been a man powered
aircraft group associated
with the Royal Aeronautical
Society for a while.
Henry Kremer was a friend
of some of those people.
And after selling a division
of one of his companies,
he had a party to celebrate
and asked one of these people
how is that human powered
airplane stuff going.
And his friend replied
it wasn't going anyplace.
They're just sitting around
talking to each other.
It was going to take
something like a prize
to make it go to get
that field going.
And Kremer, who was starting
on his third martini,
said I'll put up a prize.
And that was the deep
insight that went
into what I think is one of--
you'll find from the
consequence-- one of the most
creative activities
in the 20th century
and does get you to think
about the importance of ethanol
as an energy producer
or liberator.
Anyhow, Kremer is short
fellow right there.
And right after his prize
came out, teams in England
began focusing their attention
on really getting stuff out.
Not sure which plane this is.
It might be the Puffin.
But they built several large
span quite sophisticated,
though sophisticated--
one of the definitions
of the dictionary is
unnecessarily complicated.
You wonder why so
many ribs and so on.
Well, it's easy to be
judgmental long after the fact.
This was a great
pioneering activity.
At the time, illustrated
some of the difficulties
but illustrates some
of the successes.
And they were able to actually
get the plane like this
off into the air
under the high power
that a pilot can put out for
a very short period of time.
But it couldn't turn.
And when it crashed, it
would be six months or so
before they'd be
back flying again
because of its complexity.
Ignore the Albatross
that followed later.
But there began being various
planes that no need to go into.
If you really want
to get the history,
there are bunch of books that
give it in delightful fashion.
But a bunch of groups
did work on this.
But the surprising thing
was after the first flush
of success the
first few years, it
turned out people weren't
getting any closer
to winning that prize,
which was ingeniously--
the rules were ingeniously
put as a figure eight
flight around two pylons
half a mile apart.
Required something to be able
to turn left, turn right,
go up high enough the beginning
and the end of the flight.
So it couldn't be just some
exaggerated ground effect.
Machine.
It took long enough
so you couldn't
get by on that
anaerobic power, where
a pilot can put out one and 1/2
horsepower for a few seconds.
It had to be the aerobic
continuous power where
he's down to more like a
third or half a horsepower.
I had no interest in
the subject at all,
but I had a background that
was fairly useful to prepare me
for this-- incidentally about
the only interest I was--
like everybody in the
[INAUDIBLE] activity--
I was aware of the competition.
And I think in the 1974
MIT event I was back here
and actually saw movies of
one of those planes fly--
I think might have
been Jupiter--
and it was very dramatic
and that imprinted itself
on my mind.
But I had no interest
in the whole topic.
But I did have a background
in model airplane building
when I was a youngster and
I'd make these indoor models--
somebody else's, I'm
not a youngster here.
But thing like this
would weigh about a gram
for the model for a one meter
wingspan, and the rubber band
that powers another gram, and
they've gotten up to one hour
flight indoors with these.
The propeller just
slowly goes like that
and it moves through the
air like a fish gliding
through an aquarium.
It's a art form--
turns out to be
amazingly analogous
structurally and stability
and control-wise to
Gossamer airplane.
Is also familiar with hang
gliders because with my sons
we were playing with these
as the sport is getting
pioneered in Southern California
in the first half of the 1975--
1970s and, again, came to
appreciate the virtues of tubes
in compression,
exterior wire bracing,
simple sail construction.
Well-- and I was also involved
in streamlined bike activities.
The International Human-powered
Vehicle Association
began getting going, then go as
fast as you can with no rules.
Rules stifled bike development
for a long time now.
Just go as fast as you can and
great developments took place.
And through that I was getting
very familiar with exercise
physiology, championship
bicyclists, exercise training
techniques, and so on.
And then on vacation
trip my mind--
got away with my
mind daydreaming.
It's very hard to find any
daydreaming time these days
with so many pressures.
But the only time I've ever
gotten a big idea is when I
been daydreaming--
mind thinks for itself,
decides on what it
wants to think about,
and it was connecting
some things in my mind--
one of which was--
gotten a debt because,
as a good guy,
guaranteed somebody's note
at a bank for a $100,000 loan
to start a company
which didn't succeed.
He couldn't pay it back.
I was stuck with a note
and didn't have the cash
to do anything about it.
But I assure you that
was stuck in my mind
some place even
on vacation trips.
Your unconscious would
nibble away at that.
I was aware that--
had no interest in the
Kremer prize which I had--
I did know was up
to 50,000 pounds.
But, once, in middle
vacation going--
I looked the newspaper,
I found the pound was
worth $2 at that
time, and suddenly
this light bulb just
glowed over my head.
Why that's the same
amount as my debt,
how exciting and important
human-powered flight is.
So I began concentrating
on it very hard and tried--
I'm an aerodynamicist, I should
be able to figure things out.
But every design I
came up with were
like those people in England
that were not able to--
that didn't come
close to succeeding
with big teams, and big,
complex, elegant airplanes,
and I batted my head against
that wall for a while--
gave up, went off
did other things.
I was doing some
studies of bird flight--
timing how long it takes for a
bird to go around in a circle,
look at the bank angle, you
can tell it's flight speed,
flight radius.
And then I began comparing
this bird with that bird,
comparing-- doing the scaling
laws that relate different
size, and weights, and speed,
compared that with a hang
glider and the sail plane, and
this hobby thing suddenly--
as often happens--
I thought back about
human-powered flight
and realized, hey,
it's all solved.
There was an easy
way to do it which
is if you make something large
enough and light enough--
if the weight just doesn't go up
and you can keep making a thing
like a hang glider bigger,
and bigger, and bigger--
no matter how ugly it is--
if it's big enough, you can
fly it on very low power
and so immediately made a model.
As soon as that
vacation trip was done,
you see here that tested how
you make a very large wing.
I had no knowledge
of wing structure,
but I had knowledge of indoor
models and so on-- just
used logic.
This is the best way to make
a lightweight structure.
And that's the model.
And about two months later we
were flying the first version
of the Gossamer Condor--
55-pound weight with
my 105-pound son
flying at the time, who
would fly as slowly as six
miles an hour and had a
lot of problems with it--
in everything.
It exaggerated the
problems so that you can
identify and understand them.
But it had one
great feature which
is it was quick to repair,
modify, alter, redesign.
And if it crashed on landing--
you didn't grab it properly
as it slid a little sideways--
because stability
control was just awful--
and a tube broke, you'd
get a broom handle
and some duct tape and tape
the broom handle back on.
You'd be flying in five minutes.
That accident would have
kept those people in England
not flying for something
like six months.
So we got huge amount of
flight experience out of this.
Learned all the difficulties.
It's just so thin, fragile.
It seems as though the
shadow looks a little more
solid than the airplane does.
Well, we began
sensing the reason
for some of these problems
was an apparent mass
effect that exists on all
airplanes but completely
negligible.
The mass of air to
which you're coupled
on the plane and regular
plane is negligible
compared to the airplane here.
It was much, much
larger than the mass
of the airplane and the person.
And it was affecting
what was going on,
affecting the controllability,
and the total energy
during acceleration, during
turning, why we couldn't turn.
We used advanced computer
models on stability and control,
trying to get
answers about this.
And all the computer
models said is those flight
observations you made-- which is
there was nothing you could do
to that wing in
drag [INAUDIBLE],,
drag rotors-- that would
make any difference,
just keep flying straight and
maybe sliding off on a side.
And that's what
we saw and that's
what the computer said,
yeah, that's right.
It didn't tell us
what to do, so I
put a couple of sticks together
that had Gossamer Condor
proportions, shoved it
around in the swimming pool--
as you see here.
Here's one of the sons doing
it, with your hand just feeling
like a force balance
in a wind tunnel.
But here, you're working the
fluid almost a thousand times
denser than air so that
apparent mass effect is really
emphasized.
And within five minutes,
we had the main answers,
what the inarticulate computers
hadn't been able to tell us,
and we came up with
the final design.
A lot of the designing
in detail was
done by friendly friends who
I'd lured into the project.
It was very much a team effort.
They were experienced.
They had built
airplanes, boats, so on.
And this is the way
the drawings were done.
We never had a set of plans
until after the prize was won.
The prize was not
for drawing plans.
It was for doing
the flight, and we
didn't have to worry
about numbering plans
and storing them and so on.
Yeah, we used computers on
prop design and some airfoil
and stuff like that
when it was needed.
When this was okay,
that's what we did.
And wind took care of erasing
stuff when you were done.
It was appropriate technology.
It's not the way to
design airliners,
but that's what we did.
And a little bit on the
construction-- aluminum tube.
If the wall was too thick,
you'd chemically mill down
to the correct thickness.
And looking in the wing, just
a lot of pieces of tape-covered
Mylar.
Now we're making a
double surface plane.
And got my youngest son--
or middle son, Tyler.
Another person had been
doing the main test flying,
but that person had
to go off to Belgium.
So Tyler did a bunch
of the test flying.
Next, just working
out on a [INAUDIBLE]
to build himself up.
The amount of power you have to
put out is about proportional
to your weight.
And a young person--
older person can do it.
And he had some flight
skills and he works cheap,
so we got him.
And with a new version,
it was flying beautifully
right off the bat, but still a
lot of little problems with it
and structural and we needed to
lighten its weight and so on.
But it was kind of
going in the right way.
We then decided we--
it was going okay
and now we needed a
real pilot, Bryan Allen.
And here he is with some
of his exercise training.
We were very lucky
to locate him.
He's a gifted pilot, but
also very good on stamina--
willing to fit into such a
project, works on airplanes,
and we were just so lucky.
But the biggest-- the most
important thing in this project
was lots of luck, and getting
him was a big part of that.
Now let's have the next video--
rather than showing you a lot
of Gossamer Condor things,
this video, taken from the kiosk
at the National [AUDIO OUT]
will show some of the flying.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [INAUDIBLE] led by Dr. Paul
MacCready of AeroVironment
Incorporated.
The development of the
Gossamer Condor took a year
and was a friends
and family affair.
The earliest version
demonstrated the validity
of the team's design approach--
a huge, feather-weight, slow
flying aircraft.
- [INAUDIBLE],, the
air's speed is okay.
Sock it to it.
- It's twisted a bit.
Let's get up about 3 feet.
Okay.
[INAUDIBLE] 35.
- Let's go, [INAUDIBLE]!
- Stop pedalling!
Stop pedalling.
Pull a left!
- You go get him.
- Oh!
The [INAUDIBLE]--
- Oh, yeah.
Hold this up.
- Hold it up there.
You look--
- Hold it up there--
- Get up--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The builders learned from both
crashes and computer programs,
and they made many changes
to create the final airplane
with a 96 foot wingspan and
weighing only 70 pounds.
- Where are the nails?
- Six minutes and
two turns later,
the only obstacle left is
the 10-foot finish pole.
[SHOUTING]
On his prize-winning
flight, Bryan Allen
landed with the
words "we did it,"
a tribute to the teamwork that
made the Gossamer Condor fly
into aviation history.
[END PLAYBACK]
MACCREADY: This is a
shot during that flight.
The flight was great.
The pressure was off.
The prize was won.
A good bit of it
had been consumed.
And expenses on the project--
and there was always a team.
I'm sorry that the
only way you'll
get the idea of the teams
on all of these projects
is to read the publications.
They were not a
one-person effort at all.
The team is very important.
Here's Kremer at the
prize event in England.
Wonderful for us.
Prince Charles gave the
actual trophy and check
from the Royal
Aeronautical Society.
And setting it up in the
National Air and Space
Museum, where we have recently,
last year, cleaned it all up.
And we didn't think was going to
last there more than two years,
because it was also baggy and
floppy and tape pulling out.
But now it's kind
of cleaned up and we
put a mannequin in that
looks just like Bryan Allen
so people can see
which way it goes.
And the kiosk video
shows a lot of people
flying it after
the prize flight--
old ladies and little
kids and so on--
to make people
realize this was kind
of a person-next-door project,
not some big aerospace firm
activity.
Kremer came out
with a new prize,
taking 18 years for
somebody to go a mile.
He thought it'd take another
18 years for somebody
to go 23 miles across
the English Channel.
But we realized if we just
cloned the Gossamer Condor, cut
down the power required--
20% or so-- and
selected the right day,
the pilot could fly much,
much longer and do the job.
But now we use carbon--
now, no new ideas
in the aerodynamics.
It wasn't all that
interesting a project.
But in the structure, carbon
tubing instead of the aluminum
and many more ribs,
much more accurately
contoured airfoil and so
on, and flew perfectly right
off the bat.
But like our
previous ones, there
were various-- there
were some crashes.
And as we assess
the situation, it
looked as though to get enough
testing on this, to get it over
to England and back was going
to cost a bunch of money.
We were able to get the
DuPont company to spring
for sponsoring the
project and letting
us keep the prize money as
a carrot out in front of us.
And so the project
charged ahead.
Here doing some quick flights
as we began building--
cleaning up the first plane.
We'd put my youngest
son-- because he only
weighed 80 pounds-- in it, and
you could just push it around
and nothing would get
hurt if it hit hard.
And then fix it
up and Bryan Allen
was doing a good job
flying, but he was only
able to fly about 20 minutes
with this particular prop.
And by going to a different prop
that Jean Larrabee had designed
and people at MIT here helped
us with or actually did
the detail design.
Then we did the building.
This optimized the
prop very elegantly
for the crew's
condition on the flight.
And plane-- Bryan did a
flight of about an hour and 20
minutes, landed and felt he
could've gone on forever.
So we were off to
England miraculously.
We didn't know how
to get to England.
But in the middle of the
night, I get a phone call--
very muffled of all those
airplanes at Nellis Air Force
Base at 2:00 AM on Saturday.
And that was the message.
And so there was a C-130 from
the Royal Aeronautical Society.
Three human-powered airplanes
were all crammed inside it,
and all our
belongings, and so on.
It was just another--
good luck is more
important than anything.
Bryan Allen doing a lot
of training in England,
and training with
Joe Mastropaolo
in hot, humid conditions with
no air blowing on him in order
to get training
for what it would
be like in the plane
during the flight.
Then on the day when the
weather looked as though it just
might be okay, we're on
the Warren near Dover
getting ready for
the flight to begin.
Let's have the next.
Wait a minute, before
the video begins--
the take off, because of that
prop, was great for cruise
but it was rather
poor for takeoff
when you're going very slowly.
And we hadn't realized how bad.
We'd always done it on
big airports before.
Here we put out a little
runway, a piece of plywood.
The wing running wasn't
done quite right,
and the plane got
just off the plywood,
and the little toy 2-ounce wheel
fell into the only little hole
in that big acre of
concrete, and snapped.
And so there is the plane.
That was our start.
And this is an audience
participation exercise.
You're asked to see
if you can figure out
who is the DuPont representative
who is running the project.
But about 10 minutes
later, the plane
started on what was the
most fantastic journey,
most fantastic physical stamina
event that I've ever heard of.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Doing okay, Bryan.
You're looking good, Bryan.
You're looking good.
Heading in there, good buddy.
It's downhill from here.
- Numbly, Bryan pedals on,
no longer counting time.
His flight instruments no longer
function and his water supply
is exhausted.
When at last he sights the
French coast through the haze,
his heart sinks.
It is still three miles away.
- Go, Bryan.
- For Bryan, each moment
now has become a victory.
Dehydrated, suffering
severe leg cramps,
his judgment has begun to waver.
Briefly, he considers
crashing on the rocky point.
Instead, he fights to save the
Albatross from the turbulence
that [INAUDIBLE] added and
nearly wrecks it a few feet
offshore.
- Come on, Bryan.
- Then slowly, at
last, he's done.
[CHEERING]
[END PLAYBACK]
MACCREADY: And a
bigger team, but many
of the same members from the
first team on this project.
We never had so much
pressure, and I've never
been so exhausted.
And all the people, we
were using psychokinetics
or telekinesis or
whatever for lifting Bryan
during that whole
thing, from the boat.
It was tough.
This shows at
Aerovironment, we're
into a lot of different things.
And when these human-powered
airplanes began,
it spawned a big list of
projects that are ongoing now.
And we're growing,
I think 240 people.
We're growing as fast as we can
find really qualified people.
And it relates to ground
things and energy things,
with a lot of commonality
between all these.
There are many too many things
to describe that the Gossamer
aircraft led to.
The important point is that
it led to just so many things
that I heartily
recommend everybody
should get $100,000 debt
to get themselves moving.
And also get some projects
that don't require a product
the next year,
but let you really
explore the frontiers
of some technology.
Here's the first solar flight.
They're 80-pound sun,
still, because we
didn't have many
solar cells and that
actually climbed
a little bit just
on the power of solar cells.
This is Bionic Bat, that won
two of the Kremer Speed Prizes.
And here's a flying
telephone pole
that's very hard to describe.
But it's amazing what things
will fly out at El Mirage.
And well, I'll go back on this.
As a human power--
this is the last of
the human power slides.
This is a human-powered
airplane that our son's
figured out how to do.
And this kid can walk
a whole city block
with his hands in his pockets.
And just the up-current of
the air going around his body
and over his forehead will
keep that airplane up there.
We have not found this to
be a marketable talent,
unfortunately, and he's just
home goofing off right now.
Let's have the next videos.
Made some big planes--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
But also some little planes.
Here you see a
little thing weighs
1.8 grams zooming around the
room, and under radio control.
It's got a video camera in it,
and all the telemetry, and so
on.
Buddy will catch it on this one,
which is the preferred landing
technique.
And then on the next
go-around-- we've
flown these inside
auditoriums like this,
and now you'll see
what the airplanes saw.
It was very crude camera.
We have better ones now,
color, and higher light level,
and so on.
But you are there.
Okay, next video, please.
[END PLAYBACK]
The next video, I won't
have time today to show
you the Birdman contest.
I'm showing you
things that we did.
Birdman contest in
Japan, they have
70 human-power or
glider aircraft
fly that are just wonderful.
It's a wonderful training aid.
It seems silly.
They're all destroyed.
They go out from a 10-meter
platform over the water,
and they all land in the water,
and that's the end of them.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
But I can show you this--
"Doing More with Much Less"
that you can get a free copy of.
- Doing more with less is
a vital feature of a world
that works, where our
increasing demands are met,
yet do not overwhelm
the limits of the Earth.
Some of the unusually
efficient vehicles
with which Aerovironment
has been involved
serve as visual
metaphors for the theme.
Most dramatic is the unmanned,
100-foot, solar-powered
Pathfinder, here undergoing
low-altitude tests
in late 1993.
Versions are aimed at
eternal flight, or at least
flights for months
above 65,000 feet,
to carry equipment
for surveillance,
stratospheric monitoring,
and telecommunications.
MACCREADY: Last summer, it went
75,000 feet, higher than any--
- The fragile, 70-pound Gossamer
Albatross was pedaled 23 miles
across the English Channel in
1979 to win the largest prize
in aviation history.
It demonstrates what can
be done with low power
when new concepts of efficiency
are unleashed by challenges not
burdened by constraints
from narrow rules
or the need for
commercial production.
It is a catalyst
for new perspectives
that can lead to useful
insights and products
such as the Pathfinder.
And incidentally, it was a
tribute to the human spirit.
The more primitive and
fragile Gossamer Condor
was the first really successful
human-powered airplane.
The final version can be seen
at the National Air and Space
Museum, where it was installed
after this 1977 flight won
the first Kremer Prize.
About this time, the
International Human-powered
Vehicle Association was starting
to organize competitions
for land vehicles, without the
inhibiting effect of rules--
just go as fast as you can.
The streamlined Gold Rush
finally exceeded 65 miles
per hour, and a
two-person version
averaged over 50 miles an hour
on a 40-mile freeway trip.
Later competition
started to include
some less extreme practical
vehicle categories, no match
for our wonderful modern cars,
but valuable in suggesting
that some
transportation need not
involve large amounts
of steel and oil,
and can be healthy and fun.
Pioneering for speed
from human power
has resulted in some
amazing water vehicles.
This Flying Fish
hydrofoil lowers drag
by flying on a submerged wing.
It has been pedaled
at 18 miles per hour,
and can beat the best
eight-oared racing shells.
In 1987, General Motors
teamed with Aerovironment
for the rapid development
of the GM Sun Racer
to be entered in the
World Solar Challenge
to cross Australia on
energy from sunlight.
It won, speeding 50%
faster than the runner-up,
and averaging 42 miles per hour
on only a kilowatt of power.
Batteries to store the
intermittent energy
from the sun for vehicle use
are essential, and obviously,
for non-race
purposes, they can be
charged from the utility grid
without need for solar cells.
This solar car race
helped emphasize
that battery-powered
cars can make sense.
Next, the same team
combined to create
the battery-powered
Impact demonstrator.
To show that cars
emitting no pollution
can be part of our
transportation future,
it needed adequate range
and snappy acceleration.
Here, it zooms
from 0 to 60 miles
per hour in eight seconds.
Now many groups are
increasing priorities
on battery-powered vehicles,
vehicle efficiency in general,
and broader
transportation issues.
Impractical human-powered
airplanes, streamlined bikes,
and solar-powered cars now
seem more valuable as some
of the ideas they ignited
evolve into socially
desirable vehicles
aimed at a mass market.
Globally, bikes
are widely employed
for personal mobility, transport
of goods, and recreation.
For some uses, battery
assist, a scaled-down version
of electric car
technology, makes sense.
You can get the help of a
virtual peddler, here hidden
in the saddlebags, who
weighs only a few pounds
and never talks back,
not to turn your bicycle
into a motorcycle, but to let
you do for 30 minutes what
your normal ability would let
you do for only three minutes.
You can extend your
commuting range
with his bionic hybrid that
will never run out of gas.
You can match performance
between individuals
or not be bothered by
hills on a hot afternoon.
A tiny airplane, the
AV Pointer, serves
for surveillance,
in effect a pair
of roving eyeglasses, a
cutting edge example of where
miniaturization can
lead if the operator is
remote from the vehicle.
It is convenient to carry,
assemble, and launch by hand.
Battery powered, it is
silent and rarely noticed.
It sends high-resolution video
pictures back to the operator.
With onboard GPS, it can
navigate autonomously.
And it is rugged enough to
self-land without damage.
The modern sailplane
is superbly efficient.
Some can glide as
flat as 60 feet
forward for every
foot of descent.
They are powered
only by the energy
they can extract
from the atmosphere,
an atmosphere Nature
stirs up by solar energy.
Humans and soaring
birds have found
Nature can be generous in
providing replenishable energy.
Sailplanes have flown
over 1,000 miles,
and the altitude record
is over 50,000 feet.
The Solar Challenger was
made to serve as a symbol
that photovoltaic cells
can produce real power
and will be part of the
world's energy future.
In 1981, it flew 163 miles
from Paris to England, solely
on the power of sunbeams,
and established a basis
for the Pathfinder.
The message from
all these vehicles
is that ideas and
technology can be harnessed
to produce remarkable gains
in doing more with less, gains
that can help us attain
a desirable balance
between technology and Nature.
The stakes are high as we speed
toward a challenging future.
Buckminster Fuller
said it clearly.
"There are no passengers on
Spaceship Earth, only crew."
We, the crew, can and must
do more with less, much less.
[END PLAYBACK]
MACCREADY: Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
John Langford takes over.
LANGFORD: Thank you
very much, Paul.
And I'd like to say
thank you very much, too,
to Ed Crawley for
organizing this.
This is a great opportunity
and a great event
to put two programs
together here.
What I'd like to do, if we
could bring the first slide up,
bring the lights down
and the first slide up,
is to take up where Paul
left off, in many ways,
in the story of
human-powered flight,
and talk for a few minutes
about the MIT side of it.
And in particular, it's the
Daedalus Project, obviously,
that has epitomized this.
But I'd like to speak as
well about the whole history
of this, with an emphasis
on the role of these things
as student teaching
tools, because they
have played a unique role in
the department over the last 20
years or so.
This is the famous
image of Daedalus 88
arriving at Santorini
10 years ago
just last week, after
about a four-hour
flight over 72 miles, 115
kilometers, the product
of a three-year program
here at MIT and piloted
by Kanellos Kanellopoulos.
And it's a very great pleasure
to have Kanellos here today.
If you could stand up
for a minute, Kanellos.
This is his first
time in the United--
[APPLAUSE]
This is the first
time that Kanellos
has returned to MIT
since he was here
before the flight training.
And we're delighted
to have him and so
many other members of
the Daedalus team back.
So I mentioned
the project really
goes back 20 years or so.
And many of the themes that Paul
was talking about a few minutes
ago play right in in here.
The Kremer prize served as the
impetus for and the stimulus
for a number of student
projects beginning here
in the early 1970s.
This aircraft was one of two
called the Biplane Ultralight
Research Device, or BURD,
which were built here
in the Department by the
two teams or several teams
of students during
the early 1970s.
This was what the finished
configuration looked like.
This was about a 60-foot
span, two-person aircraft.
And as Paul has just narrated
the story of the Gossamer
Condor, once the Condor won
the Kremer Prize, the first one
in 1977 for the
figure-of-eight flight,
interest in these projects
languished somewhat.
As Paul mentioned, there was
a subsequent prize offered
for cross-channel flight.
There had been a number of
other activities here at MIT.
The one that our group
particularly came out of
was the model aircraft group
and the Model Rocket Society,
which had been actually
pioneering the techniques
that Paul showed a few
minutes ago in that micro air
vehicle flying
around inside, which
is now a program supported by
DARPA, the Defense Projects
Agency.
And one of the big advances
here at MIT in the late 1970s
was the miniaturization of
radio control technology
and its application to these
small, radio-controlled boost
gliders, here flying for the US
team in the World Championships
in 1978, where Harold Guppy
Youngren won the first World
Championship in this event.
We got involved in the activity
of human-powered aircraft.
Here you can see
there's Guppy, the world
champion on the right, and
Professor Drela in the center,
driven by the interest in this
as student projects supposed
to be fun and interesting.
As Paul alluded
to, though, there
were some very serious
aspects of this, as well.
And one of the first areas
that the MIT group really
was able to
distinguish itself in
was the design and
the application
of numerical methods to
airfoils, and particularly
to propellers.
And as Paul mentioned,
Gene Larrabee
was influential in this,
bringing the methods of Pranel
and Betz and Gloward
and updating them
from for computer execution.
And it was really a generation
of students there working
under Gene that coded that up.
And the propeller became
the first real visible
implementation of this.
This is Mark hot-wiring a
piece of that propeller,
these large, four-meter
diameter props built
in little six-inch-long
sections here.
And then, obviously, there
was interchange back and forth
all throughout this
with the two teams.
We were able to design the
propeller for the Gossamer
Albatross aircraft.
And Paul contributed
enormously to the efforts
here at MIT, providing
a lot of tips
about how these
aircraft went together,
particularly the
lessons from the Condor
and the Albatross
experience, and as
well as providing material.
All of the skin covering, the
Mylar for the first Chrysalis
aircraft that we built
were donated by Paul
as part of this.
This is the spring of 1979.
Guppy and Paul here,
and I think this
is in Henry Jex's backyard.
Henry is here today
from Santa Monica.
This was the aircraft
that resulted
from our efforts,
Chrysalis, a large biplane,
72-foot wingspan, not
really intended at the time
to be a serious contender
for the cross-channel prize,
but as a way of getting a new
generation of MIT students
into the air.
It was distinguished, I
think, by a number of firsts.
Certainly at this point, it
had among the highest number
of flights ever made,
something like 350 flights
on this airframe without a
crash or serious rebuild on it,
and holds at least one record
that continues to stand,
which is to our
knowledge, the only person
who has ever flown both
under their own power
and has flown in space is
Jay Apt, another MIT graduate
who flew the Chrysalis
among many others
in the summer of 1979 there.
The Chrysalis project
was overcome, of course,
by the Albatross, which won
the Kremer Cross-channel
Prize in June of '79, a few
days after Chrysalis made
its first flight, which I think
Paul has narrated fabulously
for us there.
And there was a subsequent
series of Kremer competitions
called the Speed Prizes
to make airplanes smaller
and hopefully, more practical.
We were able to win first
place in that competition
with an aircraft here
called The Monarch, which
was built and flown in 1983
and 1984 out at Hanscom Field
there.
The idea here was to fly
a sort of a metric mile
flight, 1,500 meters.
And the first one in under
three minutes, I think,
won the 30,000 pound
prize for that flight.
That was a great experience.
But the combination of
the Chrysalis experience,
the Monarch experience
and the Gossamer series
left a number of
us wondering where
this would lead if
it wasn't driven
by the impetus of the prizes.
The prizes certainly
provided a good focus point,
but they also put an
emphasis on how fast
and how quick and dirty
could you do this.
And there was an
element to this of,
if you didn't have
that as a stimulus,
and you were just trying
to push it to the max,
how far could one
of these things go?
How far had the technology
really progressed?
Because you have to remember,
it was moving very quickly
in this period, with
computational aerodynamics,
composite structures coming in.
How far could you push this?
And that led us
into the thinking
of was it possible to take this
all the way back to the oldest
Western reference of man flying
under his own initiative-- that
is, the story of
Daedalus and Icarus,
which was the team,
according to legend,
imprisoned on the
island of Crete
back in the Late Bronze Age, who
built wings of feathers and wax
and flew to freedom.
Two aircraft built there,
obviously, a story most famous
because of the two,
the son, Icarus,
flew in the story
too close to the Sun,
which melted the wax
holding the wings together.
And he fell to his death.
As is true even to
today, the crashes
get all of the attention.
And history had pretty
much neglected the idea
that his father, Daedalus,
had made it safely.
And that story became
the driving force
behind the idea of
the Daedalus Project
here at MIT in the middle 1980s.
This is the flight route.
When we first started
on that project,
we assumed rather
naively that it
would be possible,
as good engineers,
to go look all this up, and
find the exact flight route,
and literally recreate the
route that Daedalus had flown.
Obviously, as we began
to get into that,
we learned a lot
about a lot of things
during this project,
classical mythology
being one of the
first, and of course,
that there is no literal
recreation possible--
that myth-making is
a creative process
and builds up over time.
But applying the navigational
strategies of the day
as mariners practiced them
to the idea of flight,
it was pretty clear
that anybody who
was trying to fly from
Crete and Knossos--
the ruins were
actually discovered
in the early part
of the century here
on the north part of Crete--
the nearest major landmass is up
here, the island of Santorini,
which is 72 miles
or 115 kilometers,
about three times the distance
of the cross-channel flight,
north of the island.
And whatever your
eventual destination was--
and the myths do disagree on
the eventual destination--
the first step would have
been to get off to the island
and to get to Santorini.
And so that became the flight
route that we undertook.
So we began looking into this.
It was a research
program not only
in aeronautics, as I mentioned,
but in many other areas.
The meteorology was
an important one,
as we began to look into
the weather in the region.
Obviously, Paul talked a
little about the difficulties
that Bryan faced both in
terms of the physiology
and the meteorology.
We began to address
those right off the bat.
The existing weather
database didn't
have the resolution down
in the low-wind conditions
that we needed.
So one of the first
steps was to deploy
a series of small,
automated weather stations
there for a year or
so before the flight,
as we looked for an envelope
of weather conditions--
calm wind for four to six
hours and low temperatures.
Temperatures were very
important because of the engine.
An engine research program
was undertaken down
at Yale University.
This is Dr. Ethan Edl, who was
the project's lead physiologist
in a program that first
attempted to sort of quantify
what human performance
really was,
so that we could
use it as engineers,
and put it into the
aircraft sizing,
and optimization models.
In addition to the
physiology, probably
the single most important
technical advance
was numerical aerodynamics,
computational aerodynamics
and as practiced by Mark Drela.
I think those of you who
attended the symposium here,
it's really striking.
One of the real things that
came out of this program--
Mark's codes.
Now, of course
that may have been
a criterion for getting
invited to this symposium.
But I think that
every single speaker
there, on whichever
coast or continent,
is using a version of the
ISES or MCs or XROTOR codes
that Mark developed, and that
were first implemented here
in the Daedalus
project, which provided
the aerodynamic designs
on all of the flight
surfaces-- propeller,
wing, tails, everything.
Another big part of
this was the structures.
To get the kind of
performance we were needing,
we really had to maintain
large area of laminar flow.
That was partly computationally
done through Mark's codes,
but then we had
to implement that.
The structures had to be built
that were capable of sustaining
that laminar flow.
And numerically
controlled foam cutter
was designed and built, and
used to precisely cut out
all of the different
airfoil shapes
that went into covering
the leading edge.
You can kind of look
at the Daedalus,
and see that the pink areas
are the areas of laminar flow.
Obviously, the foam
isn't very strong,
and you have to have
a backbone to that,
which was the job
of Juan Cruz, who
is now down at NASA Langley
as their composites expert.
But this was an all-composite
aircraft with one wire bracing.
And this is a picture
of the full wing
being proof-loaded in a test
out at the Lincoln Labs hangar.
I wanted to recognize
the critical role played
by Jack Kerrebrock in
all of these projects,
because Jack has been
the project's advisor
and sponsor in this.
Every time we started
one of these projects,
once we got past the
initial brainstorming,
the first thing we had
to do was go into Jack
and ask for some money.
And whether it was
in his office here
as Department
Chair for Chrysalis
or when he was at Monarch,
we had to go down to--
he was a NASA Associate
Administrator--
we had to go down to NASA.
And when he was
back for Daedalus,
he had moved up to
the Dean's office.
And Jack has been a
critical supporter of this
throughout the whole history.
And none of this would
have happened, I think,
without his support.
We got the support
from unusual places.
One of the ones was--
the main sponsor for the
prototype of the Daedalus
was Anheuser-Busch.
And the aircraft was named by
them, the Michelob Light Eagle.
And obviously, their target
market was the college crowd.
Here's Tom Clancy modeling
for an Anheuser-Busch ad,
I think, in this one.
And that's the aircraft
flying in January of 1987
out over Rogers Dry
Lake in California.
It was flown for a series
of five record flights
by Lois McCallin
and Glenn Tremml,
including records over straight
line and closed course records.
It broke the Albatross's
record with a 37-mile flight.
And then the Light Eagle went
in and served as a test bed.
It was heavily instrumented.
You can see the
different instrumentation
that was put on it.
It became a real flight
research aircraft,
collecting the
quantitative data that
was needed both for
the Daedalus airplane
itself, for subsequent
human-powered airplanes,
and also for some of
the high-altitude things
that Paul alluded to, the very
lightweight, very flexible
structures that you need
in solar-powered aircraft,
for example.
This was a test bed.
NASA sponsored part of
their research program.
And there was a lot
of instrumentation
that went on the airplane.
Of course, all of you
associated with the project
know that the title
of this picture is--
"I don't understand.
It worked back in Cambridge."
By the time the Light Eagle
had completed its program,
we moved into the
Daedalus phase itself.
And we began the construction
of two very refined
versions of the Light Eagle,
which were the actual Daedalus
planes.
And at this point, we
began to transition
to yet another
generation of students.
The UROP program, the
Undergraduate Research
Opportunities Program,
played a big role in this.
This is Guppy here, who
served as the Chief Engineer
on the Daedalus
planes, instructing
Tom Clancy in some fine point
of how these aircraft are built.
This is Juan with
two other UROPs
here in a composite
test program,
as we began every piece of
the structure in the Daedalus
planes underwent
proof load testing.
And then the numbers were fed
back into the final designs.
And most of the construction
was done by the UROPs.
This was, at times, a
controversial strategy.
There were some members
of the department who
grumbled that the project
was using the UROP
program for slave labor.
And it was never clear to me
where they got that impression,
but anyway.
And we did work hard to employ
everybody in the program.
The pilots, even when
they couldn't help build,
we put them to work.
Here, they are selling patches
onto the team jackets the night
before the rollout.
This was the Daedalus plane,
as finished in late 1987.
The rollout was in October.
I always remember
that, because it
was the day of the great
1987 stock market crash,
and much to the dismay
of the people from United
Technologies, because there
was no mention of the Daedalus
rollout because of
the large crash.
There were other crashes
later in the program.
This was one that occurred
in January, I guess actually
early February of 1988.
This was about 21 days prior
to the shipment to Greece.
We had a Greek C-130
scheduled to come
and pick the airplane up.
And we had four
minutes of flight time.
And then we had
the airplane crash.
We lost the plane,
the first plane in--
that was February of 1988.
Fortunately, we had been
working on a backup.
And we brought the
wreckage of the first plane
back, rushed the completion of
the second airplane forward.
And by early March of '88, we
had the second plane flying.
And the cause of the accident
was essentially typical,
not uncommon in
engineering projects.
It's a failure to
communicate among two
parts of the engineering
team and the design team.
And the fundamental problem
was that the aircraft, which
had depended on its dihedral
for roll-yaw coupling,
for lateral control,
the bracing wire which
really controls that dihedral
angle was cut too short.
And that wasn't caught in
the manufacturing or checkout
process.
And the aircraft didn't
have adequate control.
Once we had traced that
problem and analyzed it,
it was very easy to fix.
And the second aircraft
flew beautifully,
made an abbreviated
series of test flights,
and then was packed up in a
C-130 and sent over to Greece.
Once in Greece, there
was a lot going on there.
Obviously, the Aegean
is a region noted
for its changeable weather.
And the aircraft
had to be protected,
so the UROPs went to work
again, and we built a hangar.
We had purchased a prefabricated
hangar and taken it over.
That team went over a
few days ahead of time.
We had secured a small fleet
of inflatable boats, which
had been loaned to us by several
organizations over there.
The engines had been provided
here in the United States.
And so we converted the
UROP team from builders
into boat teams.
The first couple of drills
here were pretty wild,
with people overboard, and
radios that went in the water,
and all of that that went
into making the flight.
But we had plenty of
time to sort this out,
because as the meteorology
got worked through--
and this is Steve
Bussolari here,
the Director of Flight
Operations on the program--
we didn't get very
many opportunities.
We knew that we
wouldn't have very many.
That we had five or six a
year was the prediction.
And we were up against
a weather cut-off,
because it would get
too hot in the summer.
We simply didn't
have the capability
to keep flying into
the summer because
of the high temperatures that we
would encounter in the region.
We did have several
false alarms,
where we got up and went through
the whole flight deployment
drill, had the pilot
sealed up in the cockpit
there, sitting on the
runway ready to go.
This is Mark, and I think that's
Frank Scioscia in the cockpit
on this, ready to go.
And then at the
very last minute,
making the call that
the conditions were
not what we wanted
all along the route,
and scrubbing the flight,
and putting the whole thing
back in.
There was a lot of waiting.
The plane was
ready and there was
a lot of waiting, which
was a very anxious period.
It's a beautiful
area there, but it
was hard to relax and
enjoy it waiting for this.
There was a lot of
other dynamics going on.
I love this picture,
because it kind of captures
all of the players we
were dealing with in here.
The military got involved
because, of course,
we were operating off
a Greek military base.
That's pretty obvious.
The Church was a
little less obvious.
The Church was involved
because the issue came up
of what if the weather was
perfect on Easter Sunday?
And there was great
debate within the team
about how to handle that.
We finally went
to the archbishop,
and briefed him on
the project, and asked
what his guidance was.
He said, go for it.
He said, if the weather's
good, you guys go for it.
Gasoline turned out
to be another factor
that you wouldn't have
thought would be a limit
in a human-powered aircraft.
Obviously, the airplane
didn't need it.
But all the boats did.
And this was the
supplies that we
needed for one day of flying,
or the boat support for a day
of flight operations there.
The people who kept the busiest,
I think, were the pilots.
We had a team of five
of them on rotation.
This was because we
had figured that this
was going to be right
at the limit of what
human physiology was
capable of, and we
had recruited and trained
five world-class athletes who
were in a rotation, much
like baseball pitchers, where
they were on for two days
and then in a rotation cycle
off for four, six,
or eight days,
depending on how
many were healthy.
Obviously, injuries were
another big part of this.
So the training regime
was very important.
They were riding hundreds
of miles each day to train.
They obviously came into the
project as excellent athletes.
They were all
Olympic-level cyclists
when they joined the project.
And in the course
of the project,
they were all trained to
be highly skilled pilots.
A lot of that was in
high-performance sailplanes.
They started in,
obviously, lower training
sailplanes, and
quickly moved into
high-performance sailplanes.
A lot of the training
took place on a simulator,
which combined a visual
out the window display
with an ergometer.
Your power was actually being
measured here as you pedaled.
And that power reading was
fed into the simulation
and displayed.
So you had the full flight
controls, as well as the power
going into the simulation.
And then once all of
that was completed,
you would fly the Light Eagle.
The Light Eagle had become
the training airplane.
And once you had gone
through this regime,
you flew the Eagle.
And one of the
requirements was you
had to get through a minimum
of a two-hour long flight,
a number of flights in
the Eagle, including one
at least two hours
long, before you
could get into the Daedalus.
And once you had gone
through all of that,
you were checked out
to fly the Daedalus.
This is one pilot's
food ration for one day.
And it's pretty amazing.
The nutritionists from
Shaklee Corporation
who were a sponsor at this time
helped go over, and sort of
rewrote the whole
diet of the kitchen
in the place we were staying.
And the pilots had this.
At first, all the
rest of the team
was pretty envious
of this, because this
looked pretty good.
But then it turned
out, as the day wore on
and they realized
that these guys had
to eat the same
thing every day, it
became a little less attractive.
The rest of the team got to vary
their meal a little bit more.
The in-flight meal service
was provided by Ethan Edl.
This is "Ethan-ol",
as we called it.
It was a very
high-performance drink
which had been optimized to
be right at the limits of what
a human could tolerate
in the system,
in terms of replenishing
the glycogen that you needed
to keep your
muscles functioning.
And Ethan had moved into this,
and had developed this drink,
had debugged it on the pilots
through various versions.
And there's actually a
toned-down version, a consumer
version, I think, that
Shaklee is still marketing.
There were, what
was it, six quarts
of that on the airplane
or something like that,
six liters, four liters.
After a period of what seemed
like interminable waiting--
it was probably more like
three weeks now in retrospect--
but we finally did
get a day where
things began to really line
up across the whole Aegean.
And the crew was brought out
at, I guess 2:00 AM wake-up.
And assembly of the
aircraft began at about 4:00
in the morning.
And the plane was put
together there on the runway.
A lot of white
knuckles in the boats,
and watching as we got ready.
And then Kanellos was given
the go-ahead and took off.
I mentioned that Kanellos was
the pilot, by luck of the draw
here that his number
came up on the day
that the weather
conditions were good.
And so shortly after
7:00 AM, Kanellos
took off from this
runway, and went
over the edge of this
embankment here, and headed out.
And the airplane which
had looked so huge when
you were up close to it suddenly
looked completely different
in terms of something
that was tiny
as he set out on this slide.
You can see in the background
there the big ferries
that go every night
to and from Athens.
And you can see the inflatables
that are accompanying it,
in case the aircraft
had to ditch.
We were prepared to take
the airplane under tow.
We had tried to absorb
all of the lessons
from the Albatross project.
And Albatross's
strategy, for example,
was to take a
fishing line and try
to hook a ring on the aircraft.
Daedalus had a
refined system that
had a tow line in the
airplane, so in the event
that Kanellos wanted
to be taken under two,
he would have dropped
the line, and the boat
underneath taken it
up, and towed it.
Navigation was done
from a command boat
following behind
the aircraft there.
This is a nice shot looking up.
You can see the carbon
structure there,
and the region of
laminar flow on the top.
It really is laminar
back to about 60%.
Pretty much you can see
where the foam goes to
on the top surface.
The bottom is
almost all laminar.
It didn't need the foam.
And here you get another view.
This is looking straight
down on the aircraft,
and again, a good view
of the laminar flow.
We had escorts provided by the
Greek Navy and the Greek Coast
Guard.
Their primary role
was in case we
needed any emergency
medical rescue.
That was provided by the boats.
And they also helped
keep the route
clear from other boats that
would have gotten in the way.
This is a great picture,
gives you a sense of the speed
at which Kanellos
was flying, and also
the crosswinds that
he was managing.
You can see the crab in there.
The boats, obviously,
and the wakes
are marking the direct flight
route to Santorini there.
And this picture
gives you a good sense
of the smooth surface of
the upper part of the wing.
This is another good example
of the "doing more with less"
that Paul was just
talking about,
where the speedboat there has--
what is that, 120
horse motor on there,
130 horse motor on the back
of that speedboat there.
The Daedalus has a quarter
horsepower motor in it,
and they're going
the same speed.
And it's all due to the
refinement of the technology
and the application of
technology to energy efficiency
here.
The flight had been projected
to take as long as six hours.
We had trained for six hours,
but the conditions were good,
and Kanellos was just fantastic.
His heart rate when he
started was about 156,
and declined
throughout the flight.
By the time we were
inside of Santorini,
his heart rate was down to
126, which still just boggles
my mind, how cool he was
throughout all of this.
Actually, by this
time, most of the team
had deployed to
the landing site,
and was watching, marking
the site there with smoke.
And then Kanellos had
the choice of going
straight in onto the beach.
A lot has been made of the fact
that the aircraft broke up.
I'm here to say, we were
maneuvering this thing
to try to get it
back in one piece.
Kanellos easily could have
gone straight in onto the beach
if the objective was just
to get it onto the beach,
but we really wanted
to try to maneuver
the airplane in and land it.
We had all seen that sight
of Bryan Allen slipping it
in there onto the
beach in France.
And that was pretty
much the maneuver
we were working on here.
So Kanellos came in
at fairly high speed,
turns in parallel to
the beach, and tries
to slip it in parallel.
Here, you can see the
beginning of the failure.
You can actually see
the buckling right there
in the carbon tail boom, as a
gust of wind, thermally induced
coming off this black sand,
catches this, torques the tail.
Tail fails right there.
The tail boom fails.
The wires or the cables
that control the elevator
are outside at that point.
So as this torques, it
puts a full-up command
on the horizontal stab there.
And that overstresses the wing.
You can see it fails out
right near a transport joint
on the right-hand side.
And the aircraft drops into the
water there just off the shore.
We had a lot of people help us
take it apart at this point.
That was no problem.
If you go to Santorini,
I'm sure there's
still pink foam souvenirs
in some of the shops there.
And there's Kanellos after
the flight, who no kidding,
could have gone on for quite
a while on this flight.
And that's the team there
on the beach, many of whom
are here today.
Could I get everybody
who was on the team
to stand up at this
point, everybody
who worked on the project?
Could you stand.
[APPLAUSE]
Many of the people I think
haven't seen each other
in 10 years after this.
And so I really do
thank Ed Crawley.
For pulling this
whole thing together.
The Daedalus project
was done for education.
It was done for research.
It was a marvelous project.
It could never answer
the question of, so what,
when people asked
it in the lectures.
But one of the interesting
things about science
when you really
are doing research
is that you never know
where the next problem is
going to come from.
And in Daedalus,
for me, anyway, it
came from a very
unexpected source.
In the mid '80s,
there were two things
that emerged that kind
of shifted the paradigm
from nuclear holocaust being
the sort of big-picture issue
that kind of hung
over all of us.
And those two issues were
the emergence of AIDS,
the breakout of that into
the general population,
and the depletion of
stratospheric ozone,
in terms of issues that when
they first began to appear,
no one was quite sure how
bad this was going to be,
and that clearly,
had the potential
to eliminate life as we knew
it in a worst-case scenario.
The ozone hole, obviously,
appeared over Antarctica
in the early '80s.
And the mid '80s,
a lot of attention
was directed towards figuring
out exactly what it was.
The primary tools
for doing that were
large stratospheric
balloons and an aircraft
called the ER-2,
which NASA operates.
It's a version of the
military spy plane.
And these worked
okay for figuring out
the causes of the
Antarctic ozone hole,
and providing the
conclusive links
between chlorofluorocarbons
and the catalytic cycles
that destroyed the ozone.
But it was also clear
that the scientists,
to answer the
question of, is this
going to spread to other
places on the planet,
is this going to happen in
the northern hemisphere,
is it going to happen
over the middle latitudes,
that you needed to go
out and take measurements
at higher altitudes and in
more places around the planet.
And a couple of us from
the Daedalus project
linked up with a group down
at Harvard in the Atmospheric
Research project
there, and began
construction of a
series of aircraft
that would attempt to
apply the aerodynamics
and the structures, and some
of the project management
philosophies that
came out of Daedalus,
and apply them to a
series of small, very
customized, robotic
aircraft that
could be used for
atmospheric science,
high-altitude research,
initially in the ozone area.
And we built an aircraft
called Perseus, about 60,
62 feet in wingspan,
developed the controls
technology for that, and
made a series of flights.
This is really to give you a
sense of scale of the Perseus.
This particular
aircraft has carried
about a 220-pound payload to an
altitude of about 50,000 feet.
And both the solar plane
and the Perseus aircraft
are working together, are joint
participants in a NASA program
that's developing the technology
for future operational
aircraft.
And we've also applied that to
a larger aircraft that's really
designed specifically around the
needs of the scientists, called
Theseus.
And that's the larger,
twin-engine aircraft
in the back.
And we have built-- this is a
140-foot wingspan aircraft that
carries between 750 and 1,500
pounds of instruments onboard,
and eventually to
altitudes of 85,000 feet
or so for fairly
long endurances.
This is an airplane
that's in development,
and is a direct outgrowth of
the Daedalus technologies.
I wanted to close here.
And if I have the time
here, which I think I do,
Corey can you queue
up this short video?
As you put that in, I just want
to close with a few thoughts
here on this picture, which
is the layered structure
of the atmosphere here, which
is really a neat picture showing
the whole path here.
And I think the lessons that
Paul has been talking about,
certainly the lessons that
we have drawn from Daedalus,
support very much the idea
that the atmosphere is,
although it looks very large,
it looks like it's an infinite
sink for many purposes,
it really isn't.
If you look at this
picture, above that line
is space, a very
hostile environment.
Below that line is Earth and
everything on it that we know
and hold dear.
And that atmosphere
is a very thin line
that separates those
two from each other.
It's amazingly under-sampled.
There's still a lot to be done.
And to the future generations of
students who are coming along,
hopefully some of whom
are in the room attending
this lecture today, there
is still a lot to be done.
And these types of programs
that Paul and I have
talked about here are
great ways to get into it.
I'd like you, if you
can cue up this video,
this is a piece that Brian
Sullivan edited together
of the flight.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
Okay, thank you very, very much.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Well, I
think we have a chance
to entertain a few
questions from the audience,
and then we'll wrap up.
AUDIENCE: I'd like to hear
the tale of the [INAUDIBLE]..
MODERATOR: Why don't-- Kanellos,
why don't you come down here
and tell us that?
And then we'll close on that.
KANELLOPOULOS: First, thank
you for the opportunity
you give me to talk.
Sorry for my bad English.
About the last
moment, there when
I was pedaling towards
Santorini was a tailwind.
So no problem, no big problems.
And over there, as John said,
because of the high speed
we had, they decide
to make me do a turn.
So we did the turn.
But during the turn,
we faced the wind.
And the wind approaching
the land was too hard.
So the plane was going up and
down, like you have seen there.
This plane was not designed
to do all those things.
So it resisted too much.
And one moment, I felt--
no, it was not my feeling.
It was real.
The plane was
flying, but staying
in the same place,
because that wind had
the speed of the plane.
So it was very tough.
And then, it took a
bank, and it was not
possible to make it return back.
So it hit it once, hit it
twice, and then broken the tail.
So it was-- but it was closed.
But I think this end, because
it was not so easy and smooth
like the other, make a very--
put fear to someone else
who wants to do the same,
that it's not so easy.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Well,
with that, I think
we'll conclude this
year's Gardner Lecture.
Thank you very much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]